Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh
, how about the time?
Enka has risen
Political parties are white
[music]
What's up
Here you go
Eh
Favorability plummets
Today's lowest value Because it's a
lie What are you doing?  There's no way I'd put it out there, but
think with common
sense.The speculator is the younger sister and the lover, and
the one who killed the skylark Continues on an aimless journey It
's a beautiful world There's no room for me to enter
Hey, I'm an observer of loneliness
Rather than going by the wall, I'm
thinking calm down, meow,
I don't say things like that at
times The career that made me fall in love is exactly two-
dimensional Under locksmith
ah ah ah ah ah ah